right and when you think about it from a
society perspective that's always
happened so who am I to say come in and
say well do it my way because I liked it
with my parents so
um I wouldn't prefer it you know I doubt
that'd be your first choice either
wouldn't be who I'd pick but I think
it's silly to say that quality woman
wouldn't do that because they have for
all of history so yeah it depends on the
guy depends on the situation I would say
like people have to choose the
relationship they want but I also talk
from a societal perspective about
monogamy and the reason I I don't tell
people what to do but the reason I
believe in monogamy is just I feel like
it's a it's a Bedrock of society like
it's something that stabilizes family
and that's good for community and good
for country and all that stuff but you
know do what you want I I agree with you
I was just thinking I was like you know
I'll give the billionaires multiple
lives
we need those jeans replicated so I'll
give I'll give them you know maybe 100
millionaires billionaires pearls Pearl's
World pearls which is satire